all right this week in isis it continues
you know our airstrikes continue we
didn't really talk about it all week
because of the election but we're
doing the airstrikes we don't seem to
know if they're helping or not actually
most of the stuff that i'm reading in
the last week it sounds like it's not
helping at all
but then there was an interesting video
posted by isis
uh on youtube uh where and it was
translated by al-antv
where a group of isis fighters are
joking about the girls that they now
have sold
into sex slavery so let's take a look
foreign
[Music]
oh
okay so in some perverse way this
actually seems worse to me than the
beheading videos because the beheading
videos
it's over right then and there you see
that it's over they are literally
selling these girls
mostly yazidi girls into a lifetime of
slavery and god only knows what
these guys are going to do with them
it's pretty awful um this isis thing is
not
getting any better huh no there is no
light at the end of the tunnel there is
nothing positive about this there's
nothing you can even spin to make it
humorous like this is tragic it's
it's it's nightmarish i mean the fact
that these women
were one of these women got a phone call
um
into a peshmerga soldier
and actually requested that somebody
please
bomb this this building that they were
being housed in to put them out of their
misery i mean it's
beyond devastating yeah um why aren't
women's rights groups talking about this
i am fascinated by this because you know
pink
uh pink code pink is one of these big
women's rights groups and they're
incredibly anti-war now i don't want a
war in the middle east i don't know that
these bombs are doing anything
but it seems to me that women's rights
groups could should be protesting this
at least
doesn't mean necessarily that means we
got to lead them to war or put soldiers
there but where
where are women standing up for women
right now i just don't get it
it's very frustrating for me and this is
something that i feel like i keep going
back to but people live in a bubble
and they only focus on what's going on
right here and that's really sad and
and i looked at the article about this
and there were only like four comments
on it only four and it just blew my mind
because i've been
recently dealing with a lot of like
feminist versus anti-feminists like hate
wars and online and stuff and like you
post one article about gamergate
where people are concerned that the
female you know trope or whatever is
being objectified and there's like
thousands of comments and people are
just
outraged but then something like this
happens and it's like you hear crickets
yeah is it partly because we just expect
that part of the world to be
incredibly backwards and sadly it just
never fails us right
so if this was happening maybe if this
was happening in france if it was
happening in the western world
obviously we'd be more upset or there
would be more of an outrage i guess from
women
but because we expect only awfulness
over there
well then i i think with this situation
there has yet to be a
hashtag trending thing that's happening
i mean if you look at the bring our
girls back like somebody created the
hashtag bring our girls back in nigeria
you know and like
then it became an issue because the
media supported it and celebrities
supported it
that has yet to happen here and i don't
know if it's because you know it's
it's isis and it's frightening and it
seems like the other and they don't want
to get involved
i think that there's this like looming
fear of
of isis i mean as it should be it's
it's a scary organization um but i feel
like people are just hands
off with it you know they don't want to
get involved and
it's intimidating so as smart
independent women
doing your thing on this planet um
i'm curious how you guys feel like just
at a personal level when you watch that
because i can watch it
and it's obviously horrific i i felt
sick almost watching it just the way
they were
talking about women like they were some
kind of thing to play with you know oh i
want the one with green eyes i want the
one with teeth
you know it's like i'll pay you you know
i'll give you a gun and you know return
for
a person yeah i mean that's how they
check their cattle that they trade they
look at their teeth that's how they
trade their livestock and it's like to
think of these women just
simply as that they're the equivalent or
even below really livestock
you know it's it's you can i agree with
you i literally feel
ill thinking about it because i go into
their mind and their lives and think
about
just the lifetime ahead of them of
misery
you